left esteemed secretary to the governor
melissa de rosa to her left
the esteemed budget director robert
mejica
thank you all for being here
appropriately social distance today's
day 220
believe it or not
the fall is here what happens in the
fall
leaves come down jimmy vielkin spends a
lot of time
with the foliage up north what else
happens in the fall
the virus goes up the leaves come down
the virus goes up they've been talking
about this for a long time they
predicted this
and on this prediction they happen to be
right you see the virus increasing
across the country
you see it increasing across the globe
you see countries that
had it under control are now struggling
struggling again in new york statewide
we are doing very well on the numbers
we have what i call a covet cluster
problem but a cluster problem
is serious because a cluster problem
can grow the virus
spreads in mass gatherings we know this
from our own experience from what we've
seen
and from what every expert tells us
right
the outbreaks which is when the virus is
spreading out of control
it starts with a mass gathering and then
it expands from there especially indoors
we've seen it in colleges
state colleges private colleges
you have that congregate
mass gathering indoors
or frequenting a bar in the case of
colleges
and it takes off we've seen it in
factory settings around the country
we've seen it
in produce plants apple plants
in new york we've seen it in a single
restaurant
can be a mass gathering we've seen it at
july 4th parties we've seen it at labor
day parties
we've seen it in the rose garden
that was a mass gathering outdoor
by the way and we've seen it
you see that growing list of all the
people who were infected from that mass
gathering
we see it in places of worship
we've seen one church infect people
we've seen
synagogues infect people we've seen
mosques infect people
we had the first hot spot cluster in the
united states of america
new rochelle a super spreader
who attended a temple service and then
attempt attended a wedding and that was
it
we were off to the races so it's to be
taken very seriously
a mass gathering causes infections
infections cause a cluster a cluster
causes community spread that is the
natural
evolution of things unless
we intervene and we stop the cycle
if you just let the cycle run that is
what's going to happen
we see clusters now across the state
colleges upstate
we have a cluster in binghamton orange
rockland
queens brooklyn nassau
the cluster is just that it's a cluster
of cases a high density of cases
and it seeps it
it grows from that cluster
almost in concentric circles drop a
pebble into the pond
pebble goes in then there's one ring two
rings three rings and the rings
continue across the pond that's how the
virus spreads
when you see the cluster you have to
stop it
at that point what's our strategy
crush the cluster and stop the spread
and we're announcing a special
initiative to do just that
cluster action initiative catchy name
step one you take the most dramatic
action
within the cluster itself where you have
the highest density of cases
understanding that the people in that
cluster interface with the surrounding
communities
take additional action in the community
surrounding the cluster
and then on a precautionary measure
take action in the communities that are
outlining that area right so three steps
first identify the cluster
you can identify the cluster because we
do so much testing and we have so much
data
we can tell you where there is a cluster
by the actual number of cases
we have the addresses of people who are
covet positive
so we have mapping software where you
can see exactly where the cluster is
that's the highest density of cases
that's where you have to take the most
dramatic action
the surrounding area is where that
cluster is going to seep why because
that's where people interact uh in the
grocery store that's where they interact
at the bus stop that's where they
interact
uh in the local recreational areas
so cluster the area around the cluster
and then as a precautionary measure uh
the area around that that's
how you attack a cluster most intense
action
on the cluster itself and then
precautionary action as you pull back
clusters all of these areas you can look
at them
exactly by the cases it's not by zip
code it's not by census tract
it's not by any political metric it's
only by the number of cases
so for example brooklyn new york we have
one area
and this is an actual map of brooklyn
the cluster is the red area
that is the area in this is basically
south
brooklyn that has the highest number of
cases
by actual data the
surrounding area orange
if that's really orange it's more like a
brownish
but that is the second
ring right that's the warning area
because the people who are
in that cluster they're going through
the same store
they're going to the same church they're
going to the same bus stop
as people in that surrounding area right
these are there were no
walls here the third
area is the yellowish area
around the perimeter
from that line straight line down
that we call a precautionary area okay
because they may very well also be
coming in contact
with the people in the cluster or
the people in the middle of that cluster
may have infected somebody in
the orange zone who may be in contact
with someone
on the yellow zone right because red is
the cluster
orange is surrounding the cluster yellow
is the periphery
so that's the actual uh south brooklyn
map
queens there are two areas
that will be mapped just the way
brooklyn is mapped
but same concept there's a central
cluster
there's a surrounding area and there's a
precautionary area surrounding that
two smaller areas in queens the brooklyn
area is larger than either of the two
queens areas binghamton we have a
cluster
binghamton we're declaring a yellow zone
which is the precautionary zone
which is a less intense
action plan than in a red zone
why because there's just fewer number of
cases in binghamton the density is less
the cluster is less
but it still requires
precaution orange county we have
an intense cluster and then
what we call a precautionary zone around
that cluster
rockland county same thing we have an
intense cluster
and then we're establishing a
precautionary
zone around that cluster
the these are relatively small areas
geographically
maybe a cluster is one mile in diameter
maybe with the
orange area
it's a mile and a half maybe with
the precaution area it's about two miles
so these are geographically
circumscribed
relatively small but that's why they're
clusters
and the trick is to keep it small
right keep the infection
from spreading so
small but intense targeted efforts
in that area and we have
new rules for a red orange or yellow
community the red which is
the most impacted area
houses of worship will be 25
capacity up to
10 people maximum so if it's a church
or a mosque or a temple there'll be a
maximum of 25 capacity or 10 people
no mass gatherings only essential
businesses open
only take out dining and schools are
closed
in the orange areas that's the second
ring houses of worship 33
capacity 25 people maximum
uh mass gatherings 10 people maximum
indoor or outdoor businesses
we close high risk non-essential
businesses
high risk are defined businesses like
gyms personal care etc
dining no indoor dining outdoor dining
only four people per table
yellow which is the precautionary zone
50 capacity in a house of worship
mass gatherings 25 people
businesses are open dining indoor and
outdoor but
for people maximum per table also the
schools in the yellow
area public or private
must do mandatory weekly
testing the schools
are and the students are people who are
very
likely to interact with people within
that
uh community and we
saw this in new rochelle all the kids
go to different schools i know but they
meet in the playground
or they're on the little league team or
they're on the hockey team
or they went to somebody's birthday
party
and they interacted so the schools are
important because you will very often
see
the schools be a place of transmission
and if two students interact at a
birthday party on a friday night
and then go to school
they then bring it home to their parents
and now we're off to the races again
we're increasing the fines for sponsors
of mass gatherings
to 15 000
we are going to be uh providing the
local governments with the
maps that we did in their areas
we'll be consulting with them these were
done
uh specifically from the actual case
numbers themselves
if there's some peculiarity uh
local governments uh have a comment
uh we'll do that today the rules can go
into effect as soon as tomorrow
that's up to the local government but no
later than friday
if a local government says we want time
to get adjusted
fine today is tuesday get adjusted
but no later than friday
testing for schools in the yellow zone
starts next week
and i am more and more concerned about
schools uh the more experience we have
uh and uh the more we get into this
the more important i think it is that
schools do random
testing uh well students
are young and they're resilient first of
all we don't really know that
uh what do we know about this virus and
not
not only do you have young people in
schools you have teachers
and we all think we're young i think i'm
young
but you have teachers and i want to make
sure we're protecting
all lives so the schools in those yellow
zones
must do weekly testing the department of
health will
set a sample number
we want to make sure it's statistically
representative and they'll set that
sample
by friday if a school needs additional
testing equipment
we they should contact us we can help
them if they want to do pool
testing they pool testing they should
contact us we can help them
these rules will be in effect for 14
days
and then we'll see where we are and
we'll see the numbers and we'll adjust
from there
we've gone through this evolving
situation
with some of the best people on the
globe who've been advising them
advising us and i want to thank them
very much for their help
local governments must enforce the law
i know i've said this several times but
we can sit here all day long
and come up with laws and rules they are
only as good
as their enforcement and a lack of
enforcement
has contributed to this problem
there is no one who can say they didn't
see this coming
we've had concerts in the hamptons that
should have never happened
we've had bars that have attracted
crowds
over and over again that should have
never happened
we've had college parties that have
often
happened off-site that should have never
happened
we have had religious gatherings
that have been circulated on social
media for weeks
and action was not taken
the there can be no surprise
the rules are only as good as the
enforcement well we have
coveted fatigue we're tired of wearing
masks
covet isn't tired the virus isn't tired
the virus still energetic and strong
enough to kill you
it's no time to be fatigued we don't
have the luxury of fatigue
and i understand these are political
politically difficult situations
i've tried everything with local
governments i said uh that i would find
local governments if they fail to
enforce the law because these are
laws that they're enforcing
a law doesn't work if
you're too incompetent or too
politically frightened
to enforce it period said aj parkinson
i also said to local governments blame
me
i understand these are all difficult
acts to enforce these are state laws
blame me i have no problem with that
moving forward i'm not going to
pass more laws that are not enforced
this is a government that is competent
this is a government that is capable
this is a government that has helped the
people of the state
through this horrendous situation we'll
continue to do it
we do it because we're effective that's
why
local governments need to assign people
to a state enforcement
task force because i want to make sure
that that is happening
new york city must provide 400 personnel
to the new york state task force
i want to thank our government partners
in this cluster initiative i've spoken
to many of them
myself today but we have
in binghamton broome uh
jason garner has been very helpful uh
steven neuhaus in orange ed day
in rockland county we spoke through some
issues today i want to thank him very
much for his cooperation
new york city we've been working with
laura curran and nassau we've been
working with
together we're going to get this done
it's not easy
but we know where the cases are and we
know what we have to do
so government has to do its job but
individuals have to do their job also
and organizations have to do their job
also
we're all citizens and it's not
government's job to catch you
it's the citizens obligation to do the
right thing
right uh you don't speed on the road
not just because you're afraid to get a
ticket
you don't speed because you don't want
to kill anyone
right you act responsibly with covert
because you want to protect yourself you
want to protect your family you want to
protect other people
and organizations have to do the same
thing
i am informing uh all houses of worship
today obviously these rules the new
rules
are most impactful on
houses of worship because this virus
is not coming from non-essential
businesses
that's not what this is about it may be
spread by non-essential businesses
the virus is not starting in schools
it may be spread by schools
this is about mass gatherings
this is about mass gatherings
and one of the prime places of mass
gatherings are houses of worship
i understand it's a sensitive topic but
that is the truth period
you want to solve the problem
acknowledge the problem
deny the problem look at a red herring
and then the problem gets worse
the problem is mass gatherings and
houses of worship colleges
and some miscellaneous
foolish behavior in bars
outdoor venues etc i spoke to members
of the orthodox jewish community today i
spoke to the leaders
of myself this morning
we had a very good conversation these
rules will apply to all houses of
worship
many of these communities have a large
orthodox population
i have been very close to the orthodox
community for many years
i understand the imposition this is
going to place on them
and i said to them i need their
cooperation
i need their partnership they're very
cohesive communities
and i asked for them to work with
me to follow these guidelines
and that was positively received
i said to them that i'm doing this
for a very simple reason because i have
such respect
and love for the orthodox community
i have been friends with them all my
life
and my father before me by the way
we go way back and it's out of respect
and it's out of love
and it's because i want to protect them
in jewish teaching one of the most
precious
one of the most precious principles is
saving a life to save a life
the torah speaks about how certain
religious obligations can be excused if
you are going to save a life
this is about saving a life
that's what this is no large gatherings
in synagogues to save a life
you look at where the infection rate is
you look at those clusters
people will die in those clusters
and this is about protecting people
and saving lives and i felt very good
about my conversation
with the orthodox community
and i thank them for their help in their
cooperation seasons change
circumstances change uh
and we change with it that's what we do
this is not a new york state phenomenon
you look at what's happening even in our
region of the country
uh new york is about 1.2 pennsylvania's
up at about 8 percent
new jersey is about 2.4
connecticut which god bless governor ned
lamont has always had
a lower incident rate than we have
but there are still facts
in life okay 101 equals two
uh night follows day
uh the world is round these are facts
okay there's another fact if the rules
are not complied with
and enforcement is not done then
the infection rate will increase
if the infection rate increases we will
be
forced to close down
we know that we've been here this is
deja vu
so let's do what we have to do do in
these clusters
let's save lives and
let's continue the economic advancement
that we're making
today's specific numbers
top 20 zip codes we're
doing two types of testing now we're
testing in the hot spots
and then we're doing the normal testing
statewide
in the testing just in the hot spots the
infection rate is about 5.5 statewide
the testing is about 1.2 if you roll the
hot spots
into the state numbers which now over
samples the hot spots you're at 1.4
percent
nine new yorkers passed away they're in
our thoughts and prayers 705
hospitalized
icu 158 intubation 72.
we're going to do this we've done it all
along because we are new york tough
smart united disciplined loving last
point is i'd like to make a comment
about the president what he's been
saying
we wished him well when we heard about
his diagnosis
with covid and we wish the first lady
well
we sent them a great new york special
care package and i hope he's
back to 100 as quickly as possible
i think the president has an opportunity
that he is missing
and i think he has an opportunity to do
a public service and i think he's right
now doing a public disservice
to say to the people of this country uh
look at me
don't worry about covid look how well
i'm doing
first of all this is a funny disease
we hope you're doing well but the
disease still hasn't run its course
and uh it's a little premature to say
i'm doing great right uh you're not
really doing great until you
test negative and then by the way there
are people who test negative
and have consequences
uh that continue for weeks
and months and months
this is a frightening virus but
the president is not analogous to
the average person in this country right
the average person gets covered
they don't get flown by helicopter to
walter reed hospital
and have a team of 20 doctors
millions of dollars of medical talent
attend to their needs receive
experimental
drugs that haven't been available to the
public
and are administered just to the
president under compassionate care
right so there's no analogy there
from a public service point of view 210
000 people died
more people uh die
in this country than uh
countries around the world that were
doing much
uh worse than we were from a public
service point of view
don't be afraid of covert no be afraid
of
covid it can kill you don't be
cavalier this is just more
denial this is where it started
and you know the president god bless him
he tells you where he's going
we know that when covert started he
knew how bad it was going to be and he
just lied about it
we know that he had the white house memo
done by peter navarro
that said millions of people could get
infected and he just lied about it
woodward's book he actually has him on
tape saying i know how bad it's going to
be
but i don't want to tell the american
people yeah
that cost this nation and that confusion
cost this nation
many unnecessary lives
and expense and pain and hardship
i was saying at that time take it
seriously
president was saying when it started
it's a hoax it'll be gone by easter
it's going to disappear like a miracle
yet none of that was true none of it was
true
he knew it wasn't true and it's not true
now to say don't be afraid
of covet denial
doesn't work it never does in life
it never does i don't have a drinking
problem
i don't have a substance abuse problem i
don't have a gambling problem denial
never works
acknowledge the problem it's a
frightening virus
be smart be careful don't
hide under your bed we're reopening
go about your business but do it smartly
and that's what the president should be
saying
anyway questions your math was a little
bit difficult to follow
you talked about wanting to maybe go to
a more granular level than uh
zip codes in the census tracts so could
you be more specific
about what's covered and also mayor de
blasio was talking about
this problem in this emerging cluster as
early as last week
so were you why have we waited so long
to take these measures
uh and particularly if there is a
question of spread within
some religious gatherings why not before
the high holidays
for many observant jewish people jimmy i
have been saying
i have been saying for weeks
every instance i put on that screen
i spoke about
the concerts in the hamptons uh i spoke
about
bars and restaurants i spoke about for
weeks
i said everything i could to get the
local governments to actually act
they didn't act we set up our own state
task force
to do bars and restaurants houses of
worship
i've been talking about for weeks
now why haven't the local government's
been doing their job
some have some have
some haven't i think it's a mix of
things
first of all think about this these are
laws they've never had to enforce before
pre-covert these laws didn't exist right
uh b these are politically
uh unpopular laws
give a person a ticket for wearing a
mask tell
a synagogue that they can't have
that many participants tell a church
they can't have that many participants
close down a concert close down weddings
in the backyard
uh it's politically not popular
another factor you have a lot of
tensions with law enforcement
in some of these communities and some of
these communities
have much larger law enforcement issues
you take new york city
a number of shootings with victims is
going
through the roof right you've had
protests in some of the upstate cities
with law enforcement at the same time so
there's a number of
factors for that my conundrum is
you know my way is all right you don't
want to do it i'll do it
i did that with bars and restaurants we
don't have the personnel
to do the bars and restaurants task
force
we took investigators from agencies all
across the state
we have like dec uh investigators
um working on that bar and restaurant
task force
but compliance works on the bars and
restaurants
we have done the compliance for weeks
we've been out there done the
enforcement
the numbers are much much better
why same reason why the state police
occasionally
will do speed limit enforcement on an
intense
level some people do the right thing
because they do the right thing
some people do the right thing because
they don't want to get the ticket
and bars didn't want to lose their
license
and when they knew we were really
checking the compliance went up
i've talked about this ocean parkway
cluster for more than a week now
and we've heard the mayor say one thing
and you basically
pin things on the mayor recently we had
the mayor propose a plan of action
and you who have the legal authority to
prove it
go until this moment attack it so what
why aren't you and the mayor working
more collaboratively on let's just
take a fact okay let's stay with facts
uh
the mayor proposed a plan
when did he propose a plan on sunday at
noon on sunday at noon
to go into effect tomorrow yeah here's a
plan all right
legally the mayor has no authority to do
this right
county executives have no authority
uh so he didn't propose a plan let's say
he
proposed something because he has no
authority to
close the school or open a school or
close a business or open a business
or put these rules in place no locality
has that authority
so he put forth a plan let's do this
by zip code and you're right it's been a
problem we've been talking about all
along
first of all it's not that simple
and you have to be smart and
you have to have a plan that's going to
work and not just a plan for the sake of
a plan
right if the plan
i passed into law was actually enforced
we wouldn't be here because
if the enforcement was done you wouldn't
have had those congregations
they were illegal
they were all ill legal well let's come
up with a new rule
well though if you're not going to
enforce old rules
what makes you think you're going to
enforce these rules
and we're going to put out more rules
that aren't going to be enforced
no uh that doesn't work it doesn't make
a change
and then people lose faith in government
uh
and uh it actually starts uh a negative
cycle but
i heard his plan by the way i have
county executives
who have made proposals i've had county
supervisors who have made proposals i
have legislators who make proposals
and i heard them we take them into
consideration
we then go to the experts and the
scientists
and say what's the smartest way to do
this and
this is the plan this is
uh not granular
this is data by case number
it's not by census track some people are
proposed doing census tracts
some people propose doing zip codes
some people propose doing counties
no government by the way does anything
smaller than a county
california will do by counties
it's tricky because you don't want if
you don't do this right you can actually
increase the spread
because you can get people from one area
walking into another area to have dinner
etc and bringing the infection with them
so this is off the actual data
with buffer zones
the plan is right the rules are right
the rules are strict
they primarily affect houses of worship
i had the conversation myself
i said that this had to be
the rules that we had to put in place
and
i want the locals to give us the
personnel
so the state does the enforcement
because the enforcement hasn't been done
so now i reduce the number of people who
can be in the house of worship
the last numbers in house of worship
were violated
you just have to make sure you're not
coming up with a new number that's going
to be violated again
and i know that i don't have a political
issue
doing the enforcement because i do
believe
it's the best thing for the orthodox
community i do believe it's the best
thing for the catholic community
and for the protestant community and for
every school
and for every child because we are
saving lives
and to the extent government's job is to
protect
this is protection
uh from the highest on the highest
level because it's literally life and
death
excuse me excuse me if i could just
weigh in quickly
this is a last resort right this isn't
something you jump to on day one and in
fact it's sort of irresponsible to jump
to it at day one because you have to
look at these numbers on a three-day
rolling average on a seven-day rolling
average on a 14-day rolling average
so you can understand whether or not
it's an anomaly
and as the governor said we've been
talking to the local governments we've
been talking to the religious community
for the last
week and a half and they kept insisting
on the fact that they could get this
under control they could get this under
control they would step up enforcement
the mayor said he would send a thousand
people
what did it yield 26 violations with a
thousand people while pictures are
appearing on social media of
mass gatherings that are thousands and
thousands of people big
so this was the last resort i think
we're being more aggressive than any
state in the country
on how we're doing this we consulted
with the best minds in the country on
the best strategic approach to do this
so that we don't make a situation worse
and send the message that this is the
way it's going to get done so moving
forward everyone understands that we are
serious that
has a heart attack and they take that
into consideration with their personal
behavior
it is not about the rules
in new york city the first rules weren't
enforced
will create a new rule
it's not about the rule it's about the
enforcement
because you didn't enforce the first
rule
i come up with a second rule if you
don't enforce it
we're right back where we started what's
the difference
now we reduce the number of people in
the house of worship
house of worship wasn't supposed to have
more than 50 people
they've had hundreds and hundreds
four weeks why because it wasn't
enforced
so now we go from 50 to 10.
look unless it's enforced you'll still
have hundreds of people it's
all about the enforcement
the state does not have the resources to
do it
i have no problem doing it i respect
the black churches i respect
the catholic churches i respect the
synagogues
i have no problem politically enforcing
it
i know they won't be happy i have no
problem doing it
my problem is i don't have the resources
i have 5 000
state police there are 35
000 nypd 35
000 we have 5 000 troopers
for the entire state of new york under
this plan
yeah they're new numbers but
the local governments have to give me
the resources
to do the enforcement that they didn't
do
which is one of the reasons we're here
did you notify mayor bill de blasio
about this before you came out because
ten minutes before you came out here
he sent out a release that said we will
close non-essential businesses in our
hot spot zip codes
if the governor if the state gives us
approval so what changed have you guys
been talking to the mayor does he even
know what this matters is
consistent with anything that i've said
well what how is this any different than
the zip code plan that the mayor
proposed on sunday so just wondering how
what changed
between your conversations with the
mayor and
between yesterday and today because
yesterday you were a hard no on closing
non-essential businesses no that's not
true
you you said it no that is no that is
not true
that is just not a fact the times
was a 100 wrong on that
uh period and i told them they were
wrong
but they still knew better and if you
listen to the radio show
i said the exact opposite
i said yeah non-essential businesses can
be closed
but it's not about non-essential
businesses
it's about the mass gatherings
it's not about the schools it's about
the mass
gatherings that's how this happened
uh that's the whole
point yeah closing on essential
businesses
close the schools it's about the mass
gatherings that is what is starting
the problem the mayor
any county executive has no ability to
close
any business i can sit here and say to
you
i think new yorkers get taxed too much
by the federal government
and i think they should pay less federal
taxes
yeah i do you know my ability to affect
that
zippo right because it's a federal law
uh i spoke to the mayor
myself about this uh yes
we will put in new mass gathering laws
which is where the problem is coming
from
in these communities primarily houses of
worship but
they have to be enforced they have to be
enforced
and i'm not going to use zip codes at
census tracts that makes no sense to me
i'm not mailing a letter and i'm not
taking a survey
use the health data do you think this
will
uh stand up in court you know in light
of the federal ruling
uh that we saw this summer that said you
can't really treat
the worship differently than businesses
yes and you know now new york is has
since then allowed
unlimited outdoor release gatherings and
50 indoors
but why do you think it will stand up
because it's illegal in constitution
if in fact if in fact
nypd has also had issues um using batons
and
protesters and things like that you know
is and i think the nypd
should be wearing masks yes otherwise
they're violating the law
and i don't know how you stand up and
say my job is to enforce the law
and then violate the law at the same
time i think
it undermines their credibility
i think it adds to
the tension that is out there now
that says that suggests
police feel that they're above the law
rather than enforcing the law
follow the law if you want to enforce
the law and the law is wear a mask
and when you don't wear a mask it could
be
interpreted that you're suggesting to
people
that i'm above the law and that would be
a mistake
for any police officers if this is
governor if
this is in fact a last resort two
questions why get the
localities until friday to get it done
it would seem to be more of an emergency
than that no
well last resort meaning
the first resort was enforce
the rules if we had enforced the rules
we would not be here today but again and
again
i'll get to your second point the rule
was no more than 50.
that was the rule again and again we've
seen this virus that a day can make a
huge amount of difference two days so
why give them three days to come
they can i said if you can do it
tomorrow do it tomorrow and then
secondarily how are you going to let
people know where the boundaries of
these areas are
that's why they're going that's why they
may say
i can't do it tomorrow because i have to
notify
businesses of these
rules so i want to take a day or two
or three to notify businesses
of the rules i can i will say
i think you should do it as soon as
possible
they'll say what you just said i have to
notify businesses of the rules
and that's going to take me a day two or
three days
and i leave that up to them so they can
do it
tomorrow or thursday
but they have to get it done on friday
doesn't that timing worry you i mean
that's 72 hours with a virus that is
spread
yes i would like to see them do it
tomorrow
but what they may make your point
that you just raised i have to notify
the businesses
so they know what the rule is
so they can follow the rule and i have
to tell them the rules before i can
enforce
the rules how will that notification
happen it depends on the local
government
some areas it's relatively simple new
york city it's more complicated
uh but they have to figure out how to
notify the businesses
in of those three sets of rules in those
three zones
right can you put back the bar chart
please with the red yellow green
they have to notify the businesses it's
less a
people issue it's not like you have to
notify them because they're really
business rules uh and they have ways
of communicating with businesses
but houses of worship
uh by the i basically communicated to
the houses of worship
myself directly but houses of worship
have to be notified
uh and then it's businesses and
restaurants have to be notified
the new york court system recently
announced that they are forcing out off
of the bench dozens of older judges
due to a 3 million budget cut or 300
million budget cut
um do you think that the court system is
acting too soon with those cuts given
the question of federal aid is still up
in there i am not
familiar enough with what they're doing
uh
to give you a response so let me take a
look let's take one more
um i've been speaking a lot with the law
enforcement here in
albany and you know they're overwhelmed
with the spike
in crime that we've seen with the
shootings and
a lot of violent crime here the law
enforcement officers are telling me they
don't
feel support from you from the albany
mayor
with this violence that they've seen and
now they're being charged with
also enforcing this cluster
ordinance so what is your response to
the police that say they don't feel the
support i mean they say that they're
already having a hard enough time
with the bail reform legislation that
passed in january they feel that
rollbacks need to be made to that
legislation they have this huge spike in
violence and then
and then now they're supposed to enforce
these rules have you been sitting down
with police and what is your response to
their concerns
these rules are primarily enforced by
department of health officials
uh beyond
the police department their department
of health
officials from the city from the county
from the state because this is these are
health orders
uh so that's uh that's who's doing this
enforcement and will be doing the
enforcement
well can we answer the question on the
violence because i'm talking ireland
here in albany the d.a the albany county
sheriff
the rensselaer county sheriff the
saratoga county sheriff
they've all told me that they don't feel
like they're getting support from you
they
are concerned about the bail reform
legislation that passed and was already
rolled back
and they are having a hard time with the
violence
in this area so are you have you had
meetings with
the officers here well now you're saying
something different
that's all i'm saying before you said
how do i expect them to enforce these
rules the police
when they're doing so many things
the answer to that is uh department of
health
primarily enforces these rules so
they're not department of health they're
albany police right so that's your
answer to that
question second question is
uh the police feel under stress
with the spike in violent crime 100
percent
i agree with him i am very concerned
about it
uh i have spoken to it and this state
has taken action
more aggressively than any state in the
united states of america
it is the combination of the increase in
crime
and the tension between the community
and the police
which is very real in my lifetime
i have never seen the kind of protests
and antagonism towards the police i've
never seen it
i've never seen the vitriol towards the
police
it is frightening it's disconcerting
to the police i'm sure they find it
highly offensive
to have themselves questioned
i don't think you should be so quick to
dismiss the protesters
in this and their concerns who believe
you have police officers who have
violated their rights
and what happened to mr floyd
being killed by police officers was very
real and you have had a long
line of people who have been killed
wrongfully by police and that is true
too and that has to be addressed
so this is not so simple
uh the police are right the protesters
are wrong
there's there's truth on both sides
this state first state in the nation
said
this has to be resolved and reconciled
the
every local government albany
every local government 500 that as a
police department
must have a collaborative where they put
all parties at the table and talk
these issues through and come up with a
new public safety plan
that they pass by the council
so your point the police can come and
say
i'm overwhelmed and i don't like this
law and i don't like this law
and uh i don't like what we're being
accused of
the community protesters can come and
say
uh i think police have abused their
authority
i think their their use of force is
wrong
and then it has to be resolved and
come up with a new public safety plan
look a lot of people say
uh not every 9-1-1 call
requires a person with a gun right
there's an old expression when all you
have is a hammer
everything looks like a nail if a person
is mentally ill
do you really need a police officer to
go right
if the issue is substance abuse do you
really need a police officer
to respond shouldn't you have a capacity
to send a mental health worker
or a substance abuse counselor
you have 5 000 police officers
what they're doing public safety
shouldn't a percentage of those 5 000
slots be for mental health
and crisis intervention that is a bona
fide
conversation that has to happen
community by community
because the answer in new york city is
different than albany is different than
buffalo
many local governments have started that
conversation
not only do they have to have the
conversation they have to reinvent their
police department
pass a law reinventing it
and they have to do it by april or
the state they won't get state funding
that's how to resolve it you know
it's they're two very strong opinions
and uh divorce is not an
option in this case because we need a
public safety function foreign policy
because that's what the that's what
these law enforcement officers are
saying that that legislation
was we had that conversation last year
right and then we reformed the law
we went all through them thank you
thank you
stimulus
you try
[Laughter]
you